[Music]
the original series then right that's
got 18 of the votes
so that paid pretty much steady
throughout the throughout the um
throughout the poll
see there's a reason why we're still
making
the original series and everything
everything star trek does is compared to
the original series you know we've got
strange rules coming up
and
one of the things for that is they keep
saying it's going to merge it's going to
be the best of new track right the best
of all trick
do you think there's a reason why the
original series is basically still being
remade or just you know those characters
are refreshed i mean i'm even saying the
strange new worlds is is basically
rehashing an old story
again
is there a reason for it was it that
good was it that innovative was it that
different
uh in terms of innovation for
uh 1960s oh yeah it was that innovative
you know there wasn't anything
really serious i i mean you know lost in
space
my favorite martian or not syrian sci-fi
flander the giants shows like that with
very popular voyage to the bottom of the
sea and that was about it that wasn't
right right right our sci-fi was
thunderbirds doctor who
and that was it
you know so
star trek again was thing but when when
star wars came out obviously and that
was such a massive
hit that that's sort of when
we sort of started getting popular
sci-fi
yeah giants i was a knight came out two
years after the original track and then
when the next generation came out that
how angry people were people seem to
forget how angry everybody was when the
next generation came out that um this
isn't star trek
uh it's it's it's peeing all over the
original
uh everyone hated it before it even
aired
and now everybody keeps going on about
this thing with woke
and you know uh we're looking at getting
new stargate and new things like the new
shows and everyone's just immediately
it'll be rubbish every reboot is always
rubbish
um and you know i'm not you know this
this show is going to be terrible i'm
not watching it everybody did that 30
years ago with the next generation
and now we consider it
they didn't have the word they hadn't
invented the word woke yet in 1966
but you know the the um
the local clans groups hated it because
of you know a or any racial kiss
uh b
um
capitalism ultimately failed
you know so there there's that and so oh
it's a communist party the reds are over
here you know in hollywood they've taken
over the jews i mean there was hot and
cold running hatred over the original
trek in the 60s because my grandfather i
mean the thing with the with the
interracial kiss is that had to be
forced that's not what gene roddenberry
wanted to do he wanted to have them kiss
and then the executive freaked out and
went now you will start a riot
we can't do that so they had that child
thing that forced them to kiss and
that's sort of like that made it okay
because i don't know yeah they don't
want to kiss each other they have to and
that was but they were still you know oh
there were still there were still
protests uh my grandfather was so pissed
off about it that i couldn't watch trek
anymore
you know that is insane yeah
he he he had his issues
really all grandparents yeah oh my god
jesus dude it's
a different generation man it's
completely different generation well you
know you might not have a different
generation but he was still on the the
the bad end of that of that i mean he
there there's people that grew up in
that generation that wasn't like him
uh still mayhem you know people i mean
it was in the paper it wasn't talked
about in church
even though his force didn't care they
touched lips
yeah
oh and then he's he's legally looking up
his eyes are open and we all know that
um a kiss with your eyes open isn't
really a kiss as well so you know
that's a almost check i always have one
eye open to make sure my wife's actually
got her eyes closed my kisser just to
make sure she's
not angry at me it's a thing honestly
[Music]